can't innovate anymore my ass once again
Apple has disappointed its Pro users
with the new M2 Ultra Mac Pro but what
if they have a master plan that runs
deeper than what it seems well that's
exactly what I'm going to dig deep into
in this video because with this Mac Pro
announcement Apple sent a bunch of clear
yet hidden messages that you may not
have noticed so stick with me on this
one as I explain what I think is really
going on behind the curtains but first
let me quickly summarize what this Mac
Pro announcement seems like apple wanted
to finish the transition ASAP so they
did it with whatever components they had
ready which is the M2 Ultra chip what
they also tossed in a bunch of PCI
Express slots to satisfy all of the
professional users at a higher price
well I guess satisfy isn't the right
word because Apple actually throttled
the Mac Pro in multiple ways which I'll
get into in a minute but it seems like
apple is putting the Mac Pro on a path
of easy upgradability being able to swap
out the chips every year or two as well
as easily swapping out the motherboard
to support new attack like PCI Gen 5
faster Wi-Fi and bluetooth specs and
more Marx tech on Twitter made a good
point in saying that if a business
already has a bunch of PCI Express cards
that they use for their Mac OS apps it
makes sense to Simply buy the new Mac
Pro and pop those in being able to take
advantage of Apple silicon's snappier
performance however everyone who bought
expensive MPX modules is screwed because
those are not supported on the new Mac
Pro but anyway to me I think Apple's
master plan for the Mac Pro announcement
was something entirely different I
believe Apple did the absolute bare
minimum to transition to Apple silicon
for either one of two reasons or
theories the first theory is that Apple
was working on huge advancements for the
Mac Pro but things got delayed so they
had to put out this disappointing M2
Ultra model right now to complete the
transition basically as a stop Gap Mac
Pro and how do I know this well for
starters apple is reusing the same crazy
Overkill power supply that was meant to
run two massive MPX Duo Graphics modules
alongside the highest end Xeon CPU and
now it's just sitting there running the
much lower power M2 Ultra chip with zero
GPU card support apple honestly could
have put in a much less expensive power
supply to save on cost but they didn't
even bother and even though the
motherboard now supports PCI Express Gen
4 ssds they're still using the same much
slower gen 3 ssds in the new Mac Pro so
basically the Mac Pro seems like an
unfinished and badly thought out product
compared to all of the solid leaks that
we were getting one huge leak that we
got from Mark German was that Apple was
working on an extreme chip with double
the performance of the M2 Ultra but that
was canceled we even had leaks from
amethyst on Mac Rumors forums that Apple
was working on this monster of a chip
with 40 CPU cores in 128 GPU cores we
also saw leaked diagrams of this four
die extreme champ so what if they're
still planning this chip but on a future
process node like the M3 extreme we also
know that Apple was working on custom
compute modules which would work
perfectly as slot in GPU cards for the
Mac Pro especially now that we know that
they're definitely not meant for the
Vision Pro headset on top of that we
even had leaks from reputable sources
that Apple was working on replaceable
Ram slots for the Apple silicon Mac Pro
but they had issues with transfer speeds
as the speed was pretty slow while
testing so what if this new M2 Ultra Mac
Pro is simply a stopgap product sets
that Apple released just to complete the
transition and the real Mac Pro we're
all waiting for is getting delayed until
next time there was even someone from
512pixels.net who said they heard that
there were people inside of Apple that
didn't even want this machine to see the
light of day believing the Max studio to
be enough to hold down the high end of
the Mac line which screams stop Gap Mac
Pro product but also brings us into
Theory number two which goes even deeper
but before we get into that I've got to
talk about the best pair of shoes I've
ever had from our partner vessi a brand
that makes a hundred percent waterproof
shoes allowing you to walk through wet
grass puddles and even snow without
ending up with wet socks which is a game
changer I've been daily wearing this
pair ever since last October and I wear
them literally everywhere to work to
church on walks Trails hikes camping
riding longboards riding bikes and
basically everywhere I go and they're
still in great condition the main reason
for that is that because they're fully
waterproof you can easily rinse and
scrub them under the sink with a
microfiber towel to get them looking new
again just look at this before and after
with my wife's vessey boots that she
loves as well as a new style for the
summer I truly believe that you'll love
them so check out a variety of busy
Styles today by using the link below to
get 15 off your order with the code Max
Tech at checkout now getting back to
Theory number two what if apple is
actually planning to ditch the Mac Pro
altogether realizing that they can make
much more profit in the long run with a
simpler prosumer focused Mac Studio just
think about it out of the entire two
plus hour-long WWDC keynote less than
two and a half minutes were spent
talking about the Mac Pro which sends a
very clear message that Apple isn't
really proud of this product nor do they
care that much about it if you think
about it Apple silicon ended up being
much better than everybody thought and
even the performance of the M2 MacBook
Air is enough for most people out there
and it's gonna get drastically better
with the M3 chip and of course that goes
all the way up to the ultra chip with
crazy levels of real world performance
so what if Apple's Mac Pro Sales started
to dry up like crazy ever since the
creation of Apple silicon and they
realized that all the time research and
cash their spending on all those crazy
Mac Pro advancements just isn't worth
the time and money we already know that
Apple was struggling with making
external RAM slots work well with apple
silicon chips since the whole point is
to keep the ram as efficient as possible
in one SOC package and same thing goes
for the GPU card support with apple
silicon which wouldn't be able to take
advantage of the unified memory
architecture and then finally what if
the M3 extreme chip was so complicated
to get running with proper scaling that
they just gave up on it so what if Apple
decided that making a proper modular Mac
Pro with apple silicon just wouldn't be
worth it and the disappointing Mac Pro
that we got was bad because they're
planning to completely ditch it in the
future but they needed to complete the
transition because they promised they
would so they came out with a crazy
overpriced seven thousand dollar Mac Pro
that matches the performance of the four
thousand dollar Max studio basically
sending a clear message to prosumers
that the Mac Pro is not meant for you
apple is basically saying that they want
to represent the Mac Studio as the new
Mac Pro for regular users and
professionals they tried doing it in the
past with the G4 Cube and the trash can
Mac Pro but that didn't work but now
with apple silicon the M2 ultramax
Studio truly is fast enough for almost
everybody out there and for the one
percent who need PCI Express thoughts
feel free to spend three thousand
dollars more they're basically sending a
message to every prosumer who was
holding off and waiting for the Mac Pro
that they can stop waiting and get a
much better deal by buying the Mac
Studio and it's honestly working you
could even say that Apple presented the
Mac Pro for seven thousand dollars just
to make the Mac Studio look like an
excellent deal for what you get
basically pivoting their marketing and
pushing most people to just buy the Mac
Studio which will be marketed as the
only Pro machine you'll need now I know
you're gonna say that real pros need PCI
Express slots which makes the new Mac
Pro great for those businesses but Apple
also sent a clear message to them as
well Apple has made it clear that the
high-end professionals should look
elsewhere since Apple has ditched a ton
of pro features on the Mac Pro first of
all there is no third-party GPU support
anymore with the new Mac Pro not even
Apple's own MPX modules will work this
means that people who need a massive
amount of GPU power for rendering like
Ian zelbo for example have to look
elsewhere because the M2 Ultra GPU is
still not fast enough going further the
new Mac Pro is limited to just 192 gigs
of RAM so the professionals who work
with scientific or mathematical
workloads and need as much RAM as
possible no longer have the option to
get 1.5 terabytes of ram so this machine
is useless for them we don't even get
ECC Ram support on the Mac Pro anymore
which is very important in the
professional workstation world and on
top of that it was revealed that apple
is using a bunch of switches for their
PCI Express Lanes instead of giving them
dedicated Lanes so the slots are
essentially sharing bandwidth with each
other basically making this worse than
the old Intel Mac Pro for add-in cards
for example if you install a new PCI
Express Gen 4 SSD into a slot at the
same time as having other cards
installed you will not get the full SSD
speed because the bandwidth is now
shared so with all that said apple is
sending a clear message to high-end
professionals that they should either go
with a Windows workstation or buy the
outdated Intel Mac Pro from 2019 which
supports all of those things that I
mentioned so with this Theory number two
it seems like apple is preparing to exit
the workstation Market completely and
putting all of their focus on the future
in the hands of two high-end products
the Mac Studio which makes more sense to
buy for 99 of the people out there and
The Vision Pro headset and whatever
models are coming in the future who
knows I might be completely wrong but
let me know your thoughts down in the
comment section below and click that
Circle above to subscribe for more
videos like this one thanks for watching
and we'll see you in the next video
[Music]
foreign